[Musica]
sono molto felice di essere oggi qui con
voi lo sono meno di avere sul palco
questo questo volume rappresenta il
volume di bottiglie di plastica
consumato da voi da noi qui presenti in
questa settimana vi ricordate il mito di
atlante che era punito da zeus e portava
la volta celeste sulle spalle bene noi
non siamo come atlante non dobbiamo
portare questa punizione sulle spalle
noi siamo uomini liberi di che cosa
stiamo parlando
noi stiamo parlando dello stranissimo
caso del nostro paese l'italia in europa
primo consumatore di acqua in bottiglia
di plastica
se l'elaborazione del censis su dati
istat dice che nove italiani su dieci
bevono acqua in bottiglie di plastica
fino a tre anni fa la mia famiglia
apparteneva diciamo a questo gruppo dei
nove su dieci che cos'è successo
e successo che a un certo punto abbiamo
detto basta basta a casa mia non si beve
più l'acqua in bottiglia di plastica
perché perché c'era un paradosso diffuso
il paradosso è che in casa noi usiamo
l'acqua per tutti gli usi la usiamo per
lavarci le mani per lavarci i denti per
farci la doccia per cucinare c'è chi non
la usa per cucinare ma molti da usa e
non la beviamo perché non la vediamo
questa domanda era lì era lì davanti a
due sacchi di bottiglie di plastica
presenti il sabato quando dimentichi di
portare giù i sacchi della spazzatura no
della plastica allora la fortuna o la
fortuna diciamo la mia esperienza
professionale mi ha consentito di
rispondere alla domanda perché beviamo
acqua in bottiglie di plastica di
trovare una soluzione una soluzione
basato ovviamente su conoscenza
scientifica
io lo dicevano prima per passione
anche per formazione sono un ecologo
microbico cioè io mi occupo mi sono
occupata sempre di microrganismi
presenti nell'ambiente soprattutto in
acqua e grazie a questa formazione ha
avuto modo di andare in giro per
l'europa sulle navi scenografiche e
quindi ho avuto molta esperienza di
laboratorio proprio pratica anche lì
dove i laboratori non sono proprio
eccezionali che cosa mi ha consentito
con sperienze mi ha consentito di
sforzarmi di trovare un modo semplice
economico per analizzare l'acqua del
rubinetto di casa e riconquistare questa
informazione perduta perché noi sappiamo
che l'acqua è potabile ma in qualche
modo non la vediamo
e allora abbiamo fa ho analizzato ho
messo su questo protocollo realizzato
l'acqua del rubinetto di casa mia
e dal giorno dopo in cui ho avuto
risultati delle analisi che erano
ovviamente ottime ho ricominciato a bere
l'acqua del rubinetto io e la mia
famiglia questo passo questo semplice
cambiamento ci è sembrato così
rivoluzionario così potente che
l'abbiamo voluto regalare offrire a
altri cittadini
e così per due anni siamo andati in giro
per la città a raccogliere campioni di
acqua non solo raccogliere campioni di
acqua siamo andati in giro a parlare con
gli amministratori di condominio
misurare le vasche portate temperature
ph guardare rubinetti parlare con le
signore sederci e divani nelle case
delle cucine proprio entrare nelle case
e controllare le acque del rubinetto che
cosa abbiamo visto abbiamo visto che 195
volte su 200 l'acqua e buona conoscenza
lasche ma quello che ci ha veramente
sorpreso e quanto poco conosciamo la
nostra acqua
ora io vi faccio vi dico quattro cose
che sono state raccolte tra le mie tra
le tante dette ma quest'anno quelle più
comuni e vi assicuro che da stamattina
da chi mi ha intervistato già bella
anche ridetto la diciamo cosa numero 1
conoscenza non conoscenza numero uno
l'acqua dura fa venire i calcoli no se
questa fosse una domanda la risposta
sarebbe no la formazione di calcoli
renali o la calcolosi non correvano con
la durezza dell'acqua non vi fate
confondere dalla parola calcaree dalla
parola calcoli no e lo dice
l'associazione italiana urologi non lo
dico io
cioè non c'è correlazione è una frase
una diciamo credenza senza nessuna base
scientifica 2 ha bisogno di un
depuratore un sistema di trattamento
qualcosa per l'acqua del mio rubinetto
io vi rispondo non come rispondo io ma
come risponde
l'istituto superiore di sanità pagina
informare conoscere scegliere no le
acque distribuite in italia sono di
qualità adeguata al consumo umano e non
necessitano di ulteriori trattamenti
quindi l'acqua arriva a potabile al tuo
rubinetto tre o le vasche tubature
vecchie
beh allora la normativa italiana sul
controllo dell'acqua rubinetto è molto
stringente i distributori sono ben
controllati e in ogni caso siamo noi che
dobbiamo esercitare un controllo sulla
distribuzione perché noi siamo i
consumatori
il punto 4 è fortemente legato a questo
discorso delle vasche cioè noi ci siamo
molto impegnati nel nostro girovagare
per la città
a dare questa informazione mancante
perché di fatto effettivamente tu lo
vuoi sapere se la tua acqua è potabile
vuoi sapere se la tua vasca e pulito e
sporca o quanta e pulito e quante sporca
e in ogni caso si può sempre fare
qualcosa per farla pulire allora
un'altra cosa che noi abbiamo sentito
dire tantissimo e che l'acqua del
rubinetto sa di cloro si può essere ma
il punto è che se l'acqua del tuo
rubinetto sa di cloro vuol dire che
l'acqua del rubinetto tu è potabile
perché il processo che la porta a essere
potabile arriva fino al tuo rubinetto
ci sono sistemi semplici che si possono
dividere per cambiare un po diciamo
questa sensazione ma basterebbe farla
scorrere basterebbe consumarla fredda e
riconquistare questa possibilità
io vi assicuro che quello che sto
dicendo non è fantascienza ed è anche
difficile da digerire
cioè non perdo non penso che da subito
dopo
voi vi sentirete liberi poterlo fare e
allora siccome ci siamo accorti di
questo abbiamo anche pensato che è
giusto che questa informazione venisse
data non da un palco ma venisse data dal
basso
e allora abbiamo pensato di mettere su
una campagna di informazione e
sensibilizzazione che si chiama baby
meno plastica perché se dall'altro canto
non bevi l'acqua di rubinetto bevi
l'acqua in bottiglia di plastica e
allora siamo partiti dalle scuole della
nostra città
cosa abbiamo fatto noi andiamo da due
anni a questa parte in giro per le
scuole della città di catania
raccogliamo l'acqua del rubinetto la
analizziamo contro forniamo i risultati
a studenti docenti dirigenti genitori
coinvolgiamo tutte le famiglie delle
delle scuola a chiedersi che acqua
bevono e quindi c'è un questionario
online che anzi vi invito se volete a
compilare per esprimere un po anche
le vostre abitudini consumo consumate
l'acqua in bottiglia di plastica l'acqua
del rubinetto è bello se partecipate
perché i dati ci servono anche per per
migliorare per vedere cosa possiamo fare
per per raccogliere informazioni utili 3
è la cosa che devo dire a me
personalmente da più ritorno noi
insegniamo ai bambini e agli studenti di
tutte le classi a fare l'analisi della
quale si microbiologica perché c'è un po
questa paura di questi batteri chi sa
che che problemi danno in realtà se tu
ovviamente una cosa la conosci la puoi
studiare la medi o comunque ne sei
consapevole ti liberi anche delle tue
paure
la campagna è un successo tra i docenti
tra gli studenti lo è meno tra i
genitori
e allora vi racconto un aneddoto per
farvi capire perché lo è meno abbiamo
fatto un'analisi una scuola della città
c'era un bambino di quarta elementare
che aveva perfettamente capito tutto
aveva capito che viveva vicino la scuola
quindi l'acqua della scuola era buona
lui viveva vicino la scuola l'acqua era
diretta quindi io posso bella scuola
come a casa dopo qualche settimana la
madre ci chiama e ci dice che doveva
doveva fare analizzare l'acqua di casa
perché non se la sentiva dimentica il
suo figlio che cosa faceva questa madre
di nascosto riempiva la borraccia del
bambino con l'acqua della bottiglia di
plastica quindi analizzata l'acqua di
casa l'acqua era buona
ha capito anche la madre la famiglia è
stata coinvolta in questo processo e
devo dire sono stati sono dei grandi
testimonial della campagna che cosa ci
dicono le nostre le nostre attività
ci dicono che nelle scuole
l'acqua è buona ma non si presenta bene
questo è un rubinetto è uno dei migliori
quindi vi lascio dire la l'occhio vuole
la sua parte
c'è un rubinetto per distribuire acqua
deve essere anche piacevole da vedere è
giusto che sia così allora noi in alcune
scuole dove abbiamo potuto abbiamo noi
di fatto sistemato la rubinetteria in
altre scuole in una scuola siamo
riusciti a coinvolgere diciamo
l'acquedotto comunale in altre scuole
vogliamo fare un modo diverso vogliamo
coinvolgere la comunità guardate che
un'area torre quella parte finale
che serve a trattenere le impurità e a
consumare meglio l'acqua costa 50
centesimi
2 euro se proprio di ultima generazione
costa meno di una bottiglia di plastica
e dura molto di più ed è utile a molte
più persone che non inquina che cosa
abbiamo capito dai questionari che
abbiamo raccolto noi abbiamo la conferma
a catania del di quello che succede in
italia cioè otto persone otto famiglie
su dieci bevono l'acqua delle bottiglie
di plastica
una famiglia su dieci bene l'acqua delle
case dell'acqua di queste strutture
diciamo più o meno utili è una famiglia
su dieci potrebbe essere la mia bene
l'acqua del rubinetto
di fatto però queste stesse famiglie
sono consapevoli che la bottiglia di
plastica non sono così tanto sicuro
perché nell'etichetta c'è scritto no c'è
scritto tenere lontana la luce del sole
e lontane dalle temperature elevate in
qualche modo da questi questi dati
emerge che c'è una possibilità una
voglia di cambiare di liberarsi da
queste bottiglie di plastica questo è
uno l'altro aspetto fa un po più diciamo
ridere mi coinvolge personalmente perché
mi capita quando vado in giro di avere
amici o conoscenti che nascondono le
bottiglie poi si vergogna oppure santo
ma guarda io la bevo solo frizzante si
scusano si giustificano ma io dico
sempre non è con me o chi come me ci
crede che vi dovete giustificare vi
dovete scusare poi vi dovete scusare con
voi stessi e con i vostri figli e con
delle generazioni future perché due sono
le cose chiare semplici cristalline
l'acqua delle bottiglie di plastica non
è più sicura dell'acqua del rubinetto
tutta la conoscenza scientifica raccolta
dimostra che l'inquinamento
l'esposizione continua graduale
permanente alle alle particelle di
plastica sta comportando a livello
mondiale un anticipo delle età precoce
della pubertà nei bambini perché molte
di queste particelle stimolo agli ormoni
sessuali
e poi se avete tanta paura dell'acqua
rubinetto pensate alla granita ceri e
arriva puntuale buona seconda cosa la
plastica delle bottiglie è un materiale
altamente inquinante lo possiamo
riciclare ma una volta che è plastica la
plastica rimane e plastica tutt'al più
diventa micro plastica e quando diventa
micro non la possiamo vedere non la
possiamo raccogliere non la possiamo
eliminare quello che io faccio oggi è un
invito chiaro semplice noi dobbiamo
riconquistare l'accesso all'acqua del
rubinetto
noi dobbiamo ridurre il consumo di acqua
in bottiglia di plastica e lo possiamo
fare prendendoci cura dell'ultimo pezzo
di distribuzione dell'acqua che è nostro
possiamo sistemare i nostri rubinetti
fare può dire le vasche mettete la cor
dice d'accordo con i nostri condomini
per fare che le vasche siano pulite
una volta in modo straordinario una
volta in modo ordinario una volta l'anno
noi possiamo in una città nuova moderna
che vuole cambiare possiamo
riconquistare lo spazio attorno le
fontanelle pubbliche quelle magnifiche
posti dove uno può andare a bere abbiamo
la tecnologia per mettere sistemi in
line di monitoraggio dell'acqua quale
abbiamo viste roba incredibile lo
possiamo fare anche noi in una città
qualunque noi ognuno di noi può invece
di portare questo peso sulle spalle può
semplicemente non produrlo
[Applauso]
[Musica]